I was nominated for an Academy Award and  I never was so scared in my life it was  about seven weeks between the  announcements of the nomination and the  ceremony and it was the most terrifying  time I ever lived through and I was  scared that we were going to win for one  thing I was anxious all the time what am  I going to wear who am I going to go  with and went with my political guru  from the Columbia student strikes who I  thought was an appropriate person to  bring me down to earth but he was more  excited than I was I think I was the  only person that year to drive myself to  the Academy Awards my assistant lent me  his 25 year old Mercedes and my date and  I Marty and I went in that car self  parked which was great because actually  there's a lot of traffic I saw people  waiting in lines for limos and it's a  major logistical traffic Castle so that  was kind of cool